[Music]
a manchester fraudster cheated the uk
government for 1.7 million pounds how
come it can't be woman chester
we're not there yet woman breast
are you proud of yourself yeah are you
proud of yourself for saying some [ __ ]
like that you kind of like it no you try
you just don't do it as good or fast i
did a really lame one yesterday i was
pretty proud of that loving that lame
was pretty good thank you thank you guys
if you support anthony's puns defend him
in the comments please please from all
of his bullying because he needs he
needs defense because he can't defend
himself
yeah
that's a hard thing to argue yet all
right so this guy cheated the government
out of 1.7 million pounds what's the
easiest way to do that he cheated he
cheated the government he pulled a fast
one pull a fast one can we get a hint
medical fraud
yeah well they get free health care so
they wouldn't need to cheat the
government right [ __ ]
is it a tax thing it um
it's almost equivalent to like a welfare
thing they get welfare in the uk oh they
wrote like i got fake dependents and
they have been paying them
bingo
bar wow good guess he claimed benefits
on 188 children 188
so glitch that don't know they're gonna
get you man what are you talking about a
[ __ ] crazy number like that how did
he even get to 180 and not get caught
maybe every year they added like a
couple like oh i got away with 13. maybe
i want a kid farm because like i'm
kidding
what is a kid farm and tail it's like a
kindergarten that's tight
you got you ever been around like a like
a couple of kids it's fun but have you
ever been around a ton of kids it's even
more fun dude i said coach chico
what do you do
did you like it honestly i know i know
what he means though like it's chaos bro
yeah it's just round it's wild it's like
the way it sounded was really really
interesting though yeah a kid farm
all right it's a it's a it's like a dog
sanctuary
but i didn't want to disrespect humans
and call them dogs you know because
they're different but
they're low-key like puppies right like
children are the puppies of humans right
yeah but then like when you let them out
into the field
during recess time
it's hilarious dude you got one kid just
running out grabbing the ball hitting
the other kid the other kid is picking
his nose the other one's [ __ ] talking
to his best friend who's the other one's
like joe can i please go home to my
parents yeah you're like you have no
parents
one kid has a [ __ ] nosebleed yeah but
maybe two how's he put it wild dude it's
like a party every single day when you
have like a 200 kids around you tell one
of them starts crying and [ __ ] it is
pretty unpredictable chain reaction like
a car alarm
oh yeah
good lord so yeah this dude all 188 of
those kids don't actually exist by the
way
it's all he made it up how did he get
away with her for so long so he was
taking care of 188 ghost kids yeah it's
a big combination of um forgery and
identity theft so it's like you're
you're claiming that all these other
people have these kids
and that they need the benefits for it
and it's all just going he worked
together with a bunch of his like family
and friends to do this it's a family
business
wow i wonder how long they've been doing
it for because i don't even know 188
names if i do this fraud i'm like john
johnny jonathan johnner johnner
they got to be j names though
bart's good at fraud well i'm trying to
do like but max the jays out then i move
on to the next one dude i could come up
with 188 british names really name one
do 10 right now off the top james
o'connor james o williams wait that's
[ __ ] that's irish bro that's irish
but a lot of irish people live in great
britain what about their first names
john williams jacob john williams ii
jacob john williams the third let me
come up with 10 10 british names go juan
gonzalez
maria gonzalez
they're spanish immigrants they just
yeah they just live in the uk bro that's
a good scheme good scheme you got to mix
something you gotta have like british
names like [ __ ] saxon or some [ __ ]
anglo
saxon
[ __ ]
arthur's
jackson arthur arthur
andrew jackson
george washington
abraham lincoln
warren those are all anglo names those
are good names benjamin
franklin
marlin merlin
dude bart's the first guy getting
arrested merlin sherlock sherlock berlin
harry potter
berlin
ethan allen
name's scary man it's funny because
we're like oh what's a british name it's
the same as american names
yes it is almost yeah yes it is just not
as many jaden's raidens and braden's
[Laughter]
what's an american name that's purely
american hulk hogan
[Laughter]
well hogan's pretty german right who has
the most american name out of the six of
us eve green
nick dunn yeah yeah that's that's right
dunn might be more american than steve
steve green reminds me of an irishman
yeah that's what's wrong yeah i remember
when i fought there was a there was a
promotion where we ought to weigh in and
stuff so like so the the uh
the guy who's running the fights is like
nick dunn and i walk up and he looked at
me up and down and goes
you don't really look like a nick dunn
he's like i said nick dung you [ __ ]
ching chong get out
all right i was like yes sir i just left
dude i walked out there when i picture a
nick dunn i'm picturing like jack
reacher bro yeah
i picture like some [ __ ] built
[ __ ] did you just see me dark as
a doorway
tom clancy yeah who's this tom clancy
the writer right
[Laughter]
the 70 year old man seven year old fat
man who sat in a desk with a pilot hat
is that what he looks like he looks like
michael crichton
who i also don't know because he's a
writer that i've never seen i thought a
lot of jewish people had the name green
because like they should they anglo-size
it or they change it like it used to be
like greensburg or something yeah and
then they turn it into like green like
green stein and they take the stein down
stein in there for sure or else stein
was that goosebumps i know
but i don't want to engage with
conversation anthony
i did it for you anthony don't worry i
did it for you but it's like a talk show
it's a talk show we're supposed to be
talking i don't want to talk to that guy
the audience needs anthony's help it's
an unnecessary [ __ ] sponge to anthony
i'm not responding
what did he say someone tell me what he
said i don't talk to anthony
one of bart's girls that he refuses
starts ignoring the ignorance you say
that he liked you that muslims showed up
and stopped talking from now just like
hanging out
just getting paid to do like crypto
that's pretty funny imagine getting
invited to a podcast they ask you a
question huh
i don't talk to him
podcast is like i don't like you
i'm not i'm not talking to bart for the
rest of the day
i'm gonna treat him like he treats girls
and call in junior high
in college and college problems you
should invite him to the [ __ ]
kendra's podcast and don't even talk to
him just talk to mike's song the whole
time
yeah do it and mike's song will try to
talk to bart but yeah bart has to talk
through mike's song and talk to you
because you guys are two people that
won't talk to each other directly right
now i'm not gonna talk to him don't be
mean to me dude bart said don't be mean
to him yeah tell anthony don't be mean
bart said go easy on them
i don't need four translators guys
i only need one
steve i got you buddy the angle needs to
make sense like make it nicer you got
some flair to it we would all relay
something different
you want to say something to him i'll
hit him up yeah you tell him to gently
[ __ ] off uh anthony said uh you could
you could go a little way there on that
one
[Laughter]
do you think back in the day when they
had like world leaders and their
translators like that like talking right
if the translators heard what the leader
said and they're like oh how do i smooth
this blow oh for sure dude have you ever
seen like those uh meetings like pretty
much [ __ ] like i don't know like uh i
don't know finland is like
[ __ ] you i ran or whatever and then i
i ran guys like this and then the
translator was like
and then he's like
he said what yeah and he had to speak
into the microphone another guy tells
the finnish guy he's like
or is that the chick who's doing the
sign language for [ __ ] cardi b yeah
yeah yeah yeah those are cool
or like someone who's never heard before
and is deaf and then sees the first sign
language is going
that's what they're saying
oh my god
doesn't know what the song is yet until
they're at the live show i don't even
want to look on this side of the table
no just patch it up come on let's patch
it up right here tell him i love him we
already have enough wars he says we
don't need one here you're okay in my
book fun fact about the war um you know
you're trying to make amends here
they're they're better oh okay yeah
so i was watching this uh
i was watching this interview on putin
right and i was like man that's so funny
this who's like speaking russian because
he spoke english before i know this guy
understands english
and then so his face is reacting to what
the interviewer says
immediately in real time so he knows
right what he's being and then the
translator like tells them and then i
read in the comments like this guy was
like yeah he understands it but one it's
like a um it's like a power move to
speak russian
because even if he could speak english
he's like i'm gonna be able to express
it in a better way but then that's my
country's language why should i be
western and then another one was like
another one was like uh um
it gives them time to respond and think
and i was like god damn man
see i would have just been like oh they
understand english so i'm just gonna
speak english i just speak english i
could use that [ __ ] at restaurants when
i don't know what i want
there you go different language when the
waiter's like and what are you having
people eat here but the way it goes and
then and then two [ __ ] idiots he's
like
i'm like wait who's the train i'm like
wait um i guess i'm fired at your
translator sorry we just got a [ __ ]
ear to ear like it's two caught two
conch shells trying to hear the ocean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you